[Musique]
les représentants du département de la
réunion et de la commune de saint-andré
inaugure la première maison des
accueillants familiaux à la rivière du
mât les bas
cette cité pavillonnaire de quatre
maisons a une capacité d'accueil de 12 à
16 personnes âgées et 2,5 accueillant
call of de très bonnes conditions
d'hébergement avec 2 belles chambres des
espaces à vivre à l'extérieur comme vous
le voyez il y à aussi donc la
possibilité demain d'avoir un jardin ici
de pouvoir prendre l'air sur le kiosque
donc vivre à l'intérieur mais aussi
pouvoir profiter des espaces extérieurs
c'est bien cette structure cofinancée
par le département et le ccas de la
commune est la première de ce genre à la
réunion et en métropole
il s'agit d'une structure d'accueil
intermédiaire entre le domicile et les
ehpad
chacun sa chambre j'ai passé à nous de
réagir aussi un peu la maison et la
petite communauté
un carton va dire avec tout ce qu'il
faut maintenant place du lien social
sur une surface habitable de 250 m² les
personnes âgées accompagnées des
accueillants trouve ici un cadre de vie
chaleureux et sécurisant il s'est pas
seulement à lyon vi et a eu envie un
lionceau cyan bien mais c'est un lieu où
il ya des activités dès sa libération
on va me sortir un mini bus spécialement
affectés pour cette marche
la première maison d'accueil on
familiaux ouvrira ses portes le 5
novembre prochain
[Musique]